hey what is up guys mkbhd here and think
about this have you ever seen
the perfect smartphone
no right have you ever seen a smartphone
hit like all five of the pillars of a
great smartphone all of those on the
nose 100 it seems like it never happens
it seems like every time you have a new
great smartphone there's always one
little thing holding it back but i think
today
that may change
today we may figure something out here
for those of you who don't already know
the five pillars of a great smartphone
from me anyway are great battery great
build great performance great camera and
great display if you can make a
smartphone that nails all five of those
things then you've made a great
smartphone that's worth buying it's
harder than it sounds but that's
something to get into
so okay great battery life yes this
phone has that it may only be a 900
milliamp hour battery but number one
it's removable and number two it's not
powering the most power hungry specs in
the world so i can pretty much guarantee
it lasts longer than your current phone
this one seems to be getting about two
to three
weeks of screen on time considering the
screen never turns off great build
quality check do i even have to convince
you it's a well-built phone you already
know it's kind of a legend for that uh
it's a little bit thick but i've said
over and over again that i don't mind
thicker phones it's mildly water
resistant it's dust resistant drop
resistant shatter resistant
time resistant
this uh this thing is really solid great
performance well this thing is snappy as
hell i've been flipping through the ui a
lot uh not really multitasking but more
just flipping really fast through the
menu options and i can see pretty much
no lag at all so performance here is
also great i threw some pretty big
numbers at the calculator and after some
key work it seems to handle it just fine
not really sure why more manufacturers
don't go with physical buttons but that
was really satisfying and i'm not really
much of a gamer but this phone actually
is such a performance beast that it
actually they just pre-load games on it
they just have games built in so i
picked snake 2 which seemed pretty
straightforward and uh
i pretty much crushed the high score
it did take a while which shows it can
definitely hold a lot in the ram i don't
i don't know how much ram it has but i
swear it it definitely held its own and
then great camera uh nokia actually took
a really courageous approach with this
one and just straight up didn't include
a camera at all i mean you know what
they say if you have nothing nice to say
don't say anything at all well if you're
not going to include the absolute best
camera why waste any space just don't
put it in at all so you actually save
you don't have anything to worry about
on the back of the phone no smudges and
also no camera bump on the back so huge
bonus points there and then great
display
okay there's not nearly enough pixels on
this one i'm gonna have to take some
points off but overall pretty complete
package i give it an eight out of ten
i'll definitely throw the wallpaper in
the description too for those of you
asking for it
okay so obviously you've gone to your
subscription box and figured out what
day it is figured this would be a fun
little project for april fool's day
happy april fool's day it's funny though
in this little project of making this
video i never i learned a lot about
these phones like i never owned a nokia
3310 this was before i owned any phones
at all so i actually bought like four of
them i this is probably just past
windows phone and market share because
of this
there's a lot of really interesting
things this phone does uh for one thing
it boots up super fast i kind of miss
when phones booted up just like that
actually has an option to update the
software i didn't try that because it
was hard enough to get the sim card
working but just a lot of cool stuff so
that's pretty much it thank you for
watching this one maybe know if you want
to see other actually old phones like
realistically covered in a video i have
a nexus one i have my first smartphone
the droid but uh there's there's stuff
out there that we can make videos about
either way thanks again for watching
again this is your annual warning to
like not pay too much attention to your
twitter feed today but if you want to
have some fun go open google maps on
your phone right now you're welcome talk
to you guys in the next video peace
[Music]
you